Domenic of course you're so well known
for Emmerdale or near the unlucky in
love bet paddy but I guess these guys
are gonna find it a little bit strange
to find you making and starring in
zombie movies when did you look for
zombie movie start and why I really fell
in love is on me film is probably one is
about thirteen or fourteen and best mate
my best mates down round Accrington
video in Accrington and and that was
before all the video nasties so they
weren't even certified so we could just
wander in and we watched all the most
appalling films in the world you know oh
you know we loved it we laughed our ends
off you know we didn't do is any how I'm
whatsoever
you know guys it's not the first time
that you've acted together at six I know
you've been in Emmerdale together as
well but what was it like being directed
by dominic and what was it like
directing Joe and what to do for three
weeks was kind of strange but also yeah
yeah the other way around so yeah I
thought was great you know and also
because then it was quite emotional in
there and it's a it's kind of there's
some really touching moments and there's
quite upsetting and because we might
certainly not with a stranger doing
these things I didn't feel silly and I
kind of felt trusted too took all that
extra mile so I think there's plenty of
Tears and emotions and it was alright
because it was Joe and we're married and
it meant that in our spare time on the
run opposite we'd planned it for a year
before we started shooting we could
rehearse it in rehearse it in rehearsing
we didn't feel silly so once we got on
the set we knew what we were doing you
know so it wasn't too bad absolutely
yeah still good for him telling on what
to do like how is it for you doing it
was great actually I mean I wasn't
nervous at all about it I mean obviously
I mean there are a few little moments we
had and Dominic saying he actually did
say at the beginning of it now there
will be times Joe and I have to tell you
what to do and you might not like it but
no no it was fine it was really easy and
it was I mean at the end of the day he's
the director isn't he so I've got to
kind of trust what he says and I do I
totally trusted
all that ended after two weeks the
normal routine of me telling him was as
it should be now I know you were kind of
cooler on this a little bit didn't you
because you were kind of sleeping
everywhere when you were filming as well
and you're kind of going from door
knocking for locations and stuff how did
that work out with you did it help
they've both been in Emmerdale and stuff
it did you know in a in a the cottage
that we use was very specifically we
really really wanted that we had a
couple of fallback plans but the one
that we wanted we just said it would
just look so much better if we could get
that one it's to find it where it was
because it was about three miles in the
middle of nowhere literally in the
middle of gnaw and that's not in the
exaggeration it is about three miles
from the nearest house so I just found
it in a little track one Sunday morning
and just had to knock on his door and he
came flying out because he always says
no visitors whatsoever and what are you
I'm really sorry are you lost
and I said no no we really like your
custody we'd lost use it as I think and
before I could finish it up so we were
in there yeah yeah but these feathers
and everything will stay out your house
you know we'll be a day in the end we
were there for like two days and you
just affair doesn't got the baked scones
for and everything so yeah we were very
lucky they were great weren't they tell
me a bit about the highlights of the
shoot for you as well I love doing the
fight scenes I absolutely love cuz I'm
quite physical and I do a lot of boxing
and stuff like that so I really liked
doing the fight scene so that was I
think that was a good fun and having the
teeth in and having all the makeup in
the eyes were a bit traumatic I have to
say but and don't really had to put them
in there without they they covered my
whole eye I didn't even wear contact
lenses or anything so but yeah the fight
scenes were really great not obviously
the emotional journey nothing was great
but I think hadn't ever done that before
in a film and so yeah that's good wasn't
trying to bite you and sort of jump on
you and throw all that so it's good fun
yeah how about you dominating and I
think like because it directs him for
the first time I think finding certain
bits of the drama where you could like
you'd have like a lighting man with
tears rolling down his eyes and thinking
oh we've done something here you know
like finding little sweet spots between
within the film and that and there and
there's little there's a little twist in
the film halfway through and then I
remember pinpointing that and just
getting that right and thinking oh great
and and the confidence grew from what
your mom's like that so yeah just direct
it was just great you know I really got
the ball got really a great crew as well
the cremator cast it just really
supportive and which it had to because
it was small and it had to just we had
to just work together yeah it's good as
you say this is your first film as well
what kind of tips would you give someone
who wanted to make a sort of low-budget
zombie future that you've gained from
your experience of doing this well we
planned it for a year we we scheduled it
absolutely perfectly and we got
everything so everything we needed for
that day was two hands with but I knew
what I was doing next but also we had a
little crew meeting first of all as well
and I just said because I am Adele and
there's no politics there everything
sorted it's a very very happy smooth
ship and that's for a reason you know so
and so I remember just saying sorry if
there's any politics or if there's a
start of any policy it's just come to me
and we'll source before I even starts
and I think that made everybody go
alright okay so there was no snipping
there's nothing every slept on the floor
you know the end of the night and we got
opened them on and went to it and it was
really great it was really hard work you
know but at the end of it there was
nobody going I don't know if you know so
it was great just keeping a half Bishop
going you know so I'd say make everybody
happy feed everybody and everybody a
glass of wine it in the night make sure
everybody's asleep in sharri's warm and
just get on with it you know be and be
friendly you know people were working
their asses off so we just have to be
you know grateful for them you're not
not being not trying to pretend to be
what adapt what you think a director
isn't shouting at people you know just
be good to people as supposed food is so
important on a set it's not I hear that
from everybody definitely thinking about
the zombies that you got in the movie
now you've made a choice to go with a
little bit faster moving guys and
there's haven't you why was that what
was the decision behind it well I didn't
know a huge amount about zombie films
anyway and so to me it wasn't
mahat to be fast because i had to chase
and they had to run and they had to be
rabid and they had to be infected and
and that was how the story was going to
work and then after it was shown I think
a few people said oh they should be
shuffling you know there's certainly
other and I didn't realize there was a
kind of well never and I thought that's
interesting so I thought well they don't
really exist today so it doesn't really
matter there shouldn't be any you know
hard and fast rules and then since then
there's been a couple of films like well
obviously 28 days later and they're very
fast but I think it wouldn't have worked
have they been shuffling the whole film
would wouldn't have worked had they been
because it we need to be running away
and getting away from them I think the
whole crux of it was that like
especially my character I'd never
experienced violence in my life and we
wanted them extended fights where I was
absolutely running out of energy and
running out of breath but the zombie
wasn't and never would until it was
killed you know anyone had killed it
dropped down and get back up and you
just think Jesus so and that saw that
they had to be fast and furious and
relentlessly coming at you with violence
or ID rather than just like bumping into
you and shine about you know yeah you
know so and I really wanted them to be
frightening you know and like job says
she does she just said you know she
designed them like that without really
prying eyes this is probably good thing
and she I you know I didn't have any
kind of background really but I think it
also works because they're so fast and
there's and you've got that frenetic
nurse of the zombies but then you've
also got the kind of the relationship
the drama going on as well so it kind of
chucks two poses quite nicely I think
yes I'm the energy that they brought in
after that they're trying to work out
the wrong intrigues and and what's going
on trying to work out what's up with
them and that and trying to work that
out as a drama then all the sudden that
films just click and all of these things
come flying through the whole film you
know which which really tops it all you
know what's the secret to keeping the
zombie genre fresh do you think because
obviously it's been so many zombie
movies over the years haven't there
there was no point in those making
another zombie film you know it really
wasn't because there's too many out
there anyway and lots of them are all
the same and the cheap and nasty so we
just wanted to bring something different
which was Joe's idea of making it a
human intriguing and also I don't think
anybody's brought an example is on
zombies give the couple a second chance
and a second bite of the Apple for
themselves as well and bring another
dimension so that's what they brought
they were an allegory for their
relationship and so that was totally
different I think I don't think any
other films done that Joe what's next
for you now well I'm doing a lot of
writing at the minute I've got a few
projects on the go and we've got
something that we're hoping to do next
year January February which will be of
the horror zombies but it will be the
horror genre but it's more of a
psychological thriller so yeah so that's
sort of working at the minute I'll be
acting in that as well I'm hoping to
yeah I think Dominick could be directing
yeah how about you dominate what's next
well I work with developing this wait
for Joe sir I see but we just wanted to
be grab attention like this ones don't
ever we just wanted to up the violence
and up the the the it's more of a human
horror as well as said there's no
supernatural side to it book the the
violence will be even more brutal and
bloody we think you know but we like the
violence in this came from reality and I
think I like that so we're going to try
and op that side of it
and finally what do you think your fans
from Emmerdale are gonna make of before
dawn and what's next for you in
Emmerdale now
well Emmerdale still you know I'm
perfectly happy there at least a love of
my life is lemon apart from my wife it's
a second love of my life
good save quick so I remain totally
honestly loyal to Emmerdale you know and
whatever they want me to do I'll do and
as long as it doesn't and encroach on
them then I'll stay doing that and but
also our side projects are gray and they
made me fresh as a daisy for Emmerdale
as well just doing something different
they haven't been skipping into work you
know fantastic guys it's lovely to meet
you and lots and lots of luck with
fellow Shorty brilliantly
you